hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
clash between paul charles morphy and
the henry edward bird in london
and this is game three not game three of
the actual match but game three that
we've been uh
we're showing and if you're just joining
the show or if you've just
joined the channel uh you might think
why is morphe
uh already uh third game in a row white
uh well the problem is it's not like if
you were challenger you get white in
every game
uh it's because not all games of this
encounter were recorded so we only have
a few games i'm not going to mention how
much because i might spoil the result
but so far we've shown two morphew has
won both of them and this is only the
third game that we're showing
so that's why for the third time in a
row morphy has the white pieces
but uh without further ado let's check
out what happens in this game
so morphe again opens with e4 as he
usually does
uh we have e5 by bird and now comes f4
morphe goes for the king's gambit
and uh yeah sorry about that uh too loud
uh we have f4 and e captures on f4
bird accepts the king's gambit so not
not the queen's gambit that everyone's
talking about these days it this is the
king's gambit we have knight to f3
and now g5 seems a bit weird playing
your pawn like this already on the third
move but this is actually the strongest
reply by black
and it is played even today in 2020
against uh
uh against the king's gambit if black
accepts uh such a challenge so here we
have h4
uh immediately threatening to capture on
g5 and now
g4 and here knights to e5 now with a
double attack on the g4 pawn
there are some lines of the king's
gambit where you can sacrifice this
knight but it's not one of them for
example if bishop to c4 and you give up
the knight
yes you you have a lot of development
you can play d4 castles maybe capture on
f4
but it's actually very easy for black to
play let's say just knight c6
captures threatening checkmate and the
just queen to f6 and black is perfectly
fine
uh white doesn't really have anything to
show for here
and you have to be extra careful because
if you capture on c7 this just traps
white's queen
and it's game over so uh although you
can sacrifice the knight
there are some lines not for real only
for fun you know uh for
to play with your friends at the bar in
the library but this is not one of them
so knight e5 and now knight to f6 bird
continues developing showing that he
knows the theory of the king's gambit
uh bishop to c4 now threatening on f7
and now
the absolute best reply d5 uh giving
back one pawn and opening up the light
square bishop
so if you capture with the bishop black
is very happy to
take away your light square bishop uh so
here we have e captus and d5 by morphy
and now
bishop to d6 blocking the pawn attacking
this knight
and saying you don't really have
anything here so here we have d4 by
morphe defending the knight and now
uh well white would really enjoy
capturing this f4 pawn so here
bird defends it with knight to h5 morphy
continues development with knight to c3
and now comes the bishop to f5 there is
uh
the possibility of just going castles
but it's uh
seems very odd since your king side is
shattered like this
uh but the white king is still in the
center of the board so it
it wouldn't be all that bad uh but okay
he went for bishop to f5 instead and now
comes
knight to e2 now here morphy misses a
great opportunity to play
uh you know very very uh well
uh creatively with bishop captures on f4
but
uh he he probably thought that he uh
would get the same amount of play with
the move he played probably didn't play
it
uh uh for for that reason but here if
you
if you accept the bishop dangerous
castles and the black is completely
busted
uh you will give back the peace and
black king is still in the center it's
just going to be very hard for example
even with the the best possible defense
f6
attacking the knight here you still get
bishop to b5 check
bishop back to d7 now is saving one of
those pieces and now after cactus here
you're gonna capture back uh sorry
capture back with the knight uh and now
after knight captures on b7 you're gonna
go queen captures on g4 and you're gonna
have a really really awesome position uh
as a rook a to d1
arrow k2 e1 is coming and after you move
the king or something like that
let's say you give up give back some
material you get this position where
uh you have uh two rooks in the night
against
uh a rook a knight and bishop and
even though black is up material white
will not uh black will not survive this
the rook is coming into the game
and well this rook will most likely
never see the light of day it will be
it will be uh a very very quick victory
for white
so instead after this bishop to f5 move
this was a possibility
uh morphy now prepares it with knights
to e2 first and now comes the bishop
captures on e5 and it is as
a move tender this position has never
been repeated again
we have d captures on e5 by morphe and
now
uh f3 so bird is on the attack and he
doesn't care he gave morphe a very
strong center he's on the attack and
uh well uh it doesn't seem like uh
uh morphy has all that much to do
however g captures on f3 we have g
captures on f3 and now morphe plays the
absolute best
bishop to g5 saying uh i don't mind
anything
and you have to well you have to try a
lot of things for example if uh
if you just capture here then queen
captures and you really you really don't
mind that
you've given up this piece here uh
because you're going to win it back
after this is attended to the queen has
to move or play something but then
you're going to recapture and you're
just going to be
in a much better position another thing
you could do although it doesn't uh
do all that much here after this f6 idea
uh sorry after bishop to g5 is maybe you
have some play here would have to check
but after king captures
there's just no good continuation here
so not really
not much you can do queen to d7 is one
option but then you get knight d4
attacking the bishop here uh attacking
the pawn
then you're gonna go after the knight e6
is always an option so
there are a lot of options here however
bird
didn't really learn a lot from his
previous game where we said that f6 was
a terrible mistake and he plays
f6 again and here it's not so bad as in
the previous game
but uh morphe just continues with e
captures on f6 and now
again it's very difficult for black to
find the move here f2 uh
is uh again a possibility but you have
no continuation if you capture an e2
that is
once again possible but after queen
captures this comes with check now
uh you don't really have a good place to
go uh
because f7 check will at some point
attack the queen if you go to f8
not really not really a lot for you to
do bishop h6
check queen captures on h5 is coming and
if king to d7
then we get the uh the exquisite bishop
to d3
and now there is really no move for
black to play because you remove the
bishop and you get queen here or you
capture and then you get uh
well just queen to e6 with checkmate
again
and even if you don't capture what
you're going to play if rookie 8
seemingly winning white's queen then you
have bishop captures on f5 with
check and once the king moves you're
just gonna block the rook's attack uh
of the queen and now black has a king on
d6 is just
it's just all over so after e captures
an f6 uh we have queen to d6 by bird
not allowing this chick to come with an
attack on the queen
uh however morphy goes for queen to d
for now now this check
comes with uh queen captures on h8 so
that's always an option
and here bird really doesn't have all
that all that many good moves uh he he
plays captures on e2
but now morphy doesn't uh rush into f7
check and picking up the rook but rather
he just
calmly uh grabs the pawn with bishop
captures
and he says okay i'm now threatening to
capture your knight with
check and also this is still happening
so
uh what are you gonna play here uh we've
queen the g3 check
uh now uh looking for some counter play
here but queen to d2 by morphe
and here we have castle so it seems like
uh white
really uh white really uh has something
here and
uh you could go for bishop captures on
h5 of course that's an option but
there's an even better move
uh one which ends the game on the spot
so uh feel free to pause the video here
and try to find such a move
while i give you a couple of seconds so
uh for those of you who were able to do
it
congratulations on picking up uh eater
rook and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's rook 8 the g1 or rook h the g1 for
that matter
uh it's all the same because the queen
is under attack and you don't have a
move uh or rather once you move the
queen
somewhere let's say queen d6 seems to be
the only square
uh now a nice discovery uh wins the game
pretty much anything wins the game f7
check wins the game you can capture on
h5 wins the game
but the more the most straightforward is
just bishop to f4
picks up the queen and that's over your
king is under attack and you don't have
anything to do once this happens
black loses the queen and it's all over
uh so
after this rook 8 to g1 bird resigned
and we now have of the three games we've
shown
uh morphe is now leading the match three
to zero and it seems like uh this is uh
staunton's weakest minion uh but
uh you know henry edward byrd was
actually an amazing player and he played
some brilliant games
and we will show a few of them maybe
even after
uh after his match against morphy uh
just so you don't think that he was like
a pushover or anything
uh but yeah i mean yeah when you face
morphe and now morphe has played already
a lot of players a lot
of games and he's now much more much
more into it and
it will be harder and harder to play
against him so it might have been better
for staunton to accept his challenge
right away
rather than to allow him to you know get
uh uh get used to playing here
you know uh over uh overseas uh but yeah
uh that's why that's why you resign here
three to zero in morphy's favor
and next game that we show uh morphe
will have the black pieces so he's not
going to be white in all games don't
worry
[Music]
but yeah that's uh that's the game i do
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank two mystery people
uh for a contribution to my channel mark
k with crafty
uh crafteva and joseph oregon for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions which are always
more than welcome you see under the
borders you use hashtag suggestion uh
when suggesting a game for me to analyze
uh and uh everything else that happens
in the chess world of course
so uh thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day